simplifica 4 a cuadrada ve y todo eso
elevado al cubo en este caso vamos a
usar la propiedad que nos dice que si
tienes a x b elevado a la n esto es
igual a a la n
por b a la n iv para darnos cuenta
porque se cumple esto hagamos un ejemplo
simple si tenemos a por d a la tercera
potencia a que va a ser igual esto esto
va a ser igual a a por b ahí está la
primera potencia por a por b ahí estaría
la segunda potencia por a por b ahí
estaría a la tercera potencia
básicamente estamos tomando esta
expresión y la estamos multiplicando por
sí misma tres veces ahora estos términos
podemos intercalar los usando la
propiedad conmutativa y asociativa de la
multiplicación
así es que intercambiando estos
intercambiando el orden el que se están
multiplicando esto lo puedo escribir
como ahora por a por b por b por b aquí
tenemos tres as y tres veces así es que
esto de aquí es al cubo y estoy aquí es
b al cubo tenemos al cubo por d al cubo
funcionó la propiedad y espero que hayas
podido ver por qué esta propiedad
funciona apliquemos la al problema que
tenemos
4a cuadrada de y eso elevado al cubo lo
que significa que cada uno de los
elementos de este producto se van a
elevar al cubo esto va a ser igual a 4
elevado al cubo por a cuadrada elevado
al cubo por b elevado al cubo déjame
usar aquí el color para codificar esto
aquí tenemos este cubo estamos hablando
4 al cubo a 4 lo estamos hablando al
cubo y b lo estamos elevando al cubo en
vez de hacer el producto primero y luego
elevar al cubo estamos elevando al cubo
primero y posteriormente vamos a hacer
el producto eso es lo que estamos
haciendo vamos a simplificar esto cuánto
es 4 al cubo 4 al cubo es 4 a la 1 es 44
al cuadrado es 16 4 al cubo es 16 por 4
16 por 4 es 64 y luego tenemos al
cuadrado y eso elevado al cubo y sabemos
por la regla el producto de los
exponentes que eso va a ser igual a ha
elevado a las dos por tres
o ha elevado a la sexta a la sexta el 6
sale de dos por tres y finalmente
tenemos de kubica
voy a hacerlo con un color distinto
tenemos la ve cúbica y hemos
simplificado la expresión a 64 a la
sexta de kubica